spear slashing madness building towards
a mortar strike to turn the tide of
battle we're going back into dauntless
to look at how to get the best out of
that war Pike hello and welcome to
Playstation grenade house dauntless
treating you are you ready to give the
wall Pike another go it perfectly mixes
together the Flair and ease of the chain
blades to the tactical skill set and
stamina management needed to wield the
ax and Hammer with a little time the war
Pike could be your new Bey let's start
out by outlining the role of the wall
pipe user the spear element is the
slashing and piercing weapon which
primarily opens up wound on a vehement
for the team to take advantage of and
deal additional damage to each body part
here's our standard piercing attack is
super simple
spam away on the square button to get
the most out of this combo press Square
four times but on the fifth input hold
down that button this gives us a stamina
draining multiple slab move infused with
ether goodness the key point to notice
here about the square attacks is that we
are stuck in one position completely
stationary arguably a sitting duck and
that's where our second combo comes to
our aid our triangle combo consists of
three successive presses to perform a
harvesting attack string instead of a
stabbing motion this attack is full of
flare and slashes the behemoth and get
this we can move around whilst using it
perfect for keeping up with the Beast
and maximizing that combo the final
button press places us in a long
animation which can cause excellent
damage but we need to remember one thing
cancelling we can simply roll to stop
this animation instead of waiting for it
to end in the right scenario this is a
necessity to make best use of both of
these combos we can in fact merge them
together cross combo at a base level try
four square inputs are followed by three
triangle inputs to atha infuse your
harvesting attacks the world is your
oyster here try different variations of
square and triangle
puts to find out what works best for you
and what works best against each
behemoth you fight the only rule is how
this combo ends either through the
standing multiple stab or the whirlwind
as a basic rule use triangle attacks to
keep up with a moving target and
intersperse that with square attacks to
open wounds just don't stay still for
too long cross combos completely
revolutionize this weapon there's a very
important second reason we have piercing
and slashing attacks they actually have
different uses on the battlefield
piercing attacks
that's our square button combo are all
about thrusting forward the spear
element and opening up wounds those are
the gashes that appear on the behemoths
this in turn force is that for Hema to
take more damage on specific body parts
the slashing attack on the other hand
that's the triangle buttons that's where
the blade cuts across the target and is
used to cause damage by combining both
you will maximize your attack numbers
and by the way I'll link a video
explaining attack numbers as it's quite
confusing knowing the difference between
red blue white and yellow so give it a
watch if that didn't make any sense to
you and the final point about combos are
the stamina they use learning to balance
moves which don't use stamina with those
that do is the real skill using the wall
pike luckily we can still pull off many
stamina based moves without stamina
although there is a drop-off of course
speaking of stamina we have a running
spear attack the pike charge is
completed by holding square whilst
running with your weapon out
it absolutely murders your stamina meter
and I can't use it to save my life
but maybe you're able to use it I wish
you'd look our final attacks are
fantastic ways to close the ground on a
behemoth and setup attack combos rolling
attacks while strolling press square to
lunge into a piercing attack to open a
wound or try the triangle variant to
cause face damage follow that up with a
combo to maximize effectiveness right
let's look at the bar in the top corner
this bar fills up every time we land an
attack a great thing to notice is that
we do more damage the
further up this bar goes this makes
dodging imperative as being hit by the
behemoth
will lower that gauge and thus reduces
our attack power but there is another
use for that meter the mortar attack our
ether missiles we have a projectile
weapon built into our war pike as our
attack bar builds up we have the ability
to turn that energy into a mortar strike
to do this we simply press r1 the
animation is nice and quick to fire the
rocket we simply hold our 1 again like
this oh that wasn't supposed to happen
but let's break that down there is an
aim animation which slowly light up our
shots showing the perfect moment to fire
if we shoot too early or too late the
missile will be out of control
luckily though if the beast is directly
in front of us right in our face at
point-blank distance the mata will hit
either way the damage numbers of each
rocket is dictated by how much energy we
have stored prior to pressing r1 so
banking a weak shot will result in power
damage numbers honking a strong shot
will result in high damage easy enough
to remember so always keep an eye on
that gauge when storing Rockets here's
the best bit though the main use of the
mortar doesn't require high-level
projectiles my advice may sound strange
but it's always to have a mortar saved
regardless of the power level and this
is because we're going to Boop with it
[Music]
booping' or interrupting a behemoth is
the bee's knees it's the mutts nuts
catching a breached off-balance and
causing it to fall opens up the
opportunity for massive combos of damage
so when an ember main runs at you use
your mortar to puff it when a shriek
flies your way
Boop it's always remember weak mortars
are just as good as strong ones for this
task
so Boop away but when here's a great tip
if you decide not to use your martyr mid
animation or maybe you've missed your
opening simply roll to cancel the shot
the stored energy will stay in the [ __ ]
Ike for the next time you use it this is
a godsend so star projectiles by role
cancelling to progress from this if you
can't find a Boop opportunity against
one of the behemoths you're fighting
then simply don't Bank any shots no need
to save them instead go for that damage
buff get the gauge as high as possible
and go to town on that behemoth the
higher the gauge the higher our attack
damage so there we have it
a super quick look at getting the best
out of your time with the warp Ike a
spear of death I'd love to know your
thoughts and if I've missed anything put
it in the comments below and I'll heart
your comment thanks for your time I much
appreciate it and hopefully I'll see you
soon in dauntless I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a bloody
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]